today we're talking about how you can
play the overwatch 2 beta what you can
expect from the dying light 2 update and
more
blizzard has shared new details
regarding its plans for overwatch 2
which include getting the pvp component
of the shooter into players hands while
it continues to work on the pve side of
things that plan will begin with a
closed alpha today followed by a public
beta that includes a wider pool of
players starting in april the closed
alpha test that begins today is likely
something you can't participate in it
will feature blizzard employees
overwatch league players and a few other
select groups ahead of a beta that will
start in late april for pc players in
all regions that april test will be a
closed beta but you can sign up now to
request access to it on the game's
official website access will come in
waves so even if you don't get in right
away you may still be invited in later
more details on what to expect from the
beta are still to be confirmed but
blizzard did say it will feature the new
push game mode 4 new maps a new damage
hero and reworks to various heroes it
will also of course feature the new 5v5
gameplay style being introduced for
overwatch 2. when it does arrive the pvp
mode will integrate with that of the
first game allowing overwatch 1 players
to use new heroes and play on new maps
it's also important to note that
overwatch 2 does not yet have a release
date alongside diablo 4 blizzard delayed
its release late last year and we may
not see either game until 2023
but okay now let's switch gears to
another game with two in the title dying
light 2.
they're they're hard sometimes what can
i say dying light 2 stay human has just
rolled out a brand new patch adding a
number of player requested features and
fixing many of the game's worst bugs
including lingering issues with death
loops the patch is live now for pc and
will be coming to consoles soon
according to developer techlan the patch
includes a number of quality of life
improvements including better ragdoll
physics performance upgrades for older
pcs and what teclan describes as quote
more immersive details in melee combat
digging into the patch notes for update
1.2 these details include tweaks that
take into account the weight of blunt
melee weapons being used a buff for the
biter and changes to sharp weapons that
allow more gory slicing dicing and
general bloodshed in terms of fixes the
patch has cleaned up the remaining known
instances of what have been referred to
as death loops where players find
themselves dying over and over in
certain circumstances the patch also
adds a number of fixes to story quests
where progression could potentially be
blocked you can check out the full list
of patch notes on gamespot.com
now let's talk about some hardware
because for those of you lucky enough to
have a steam deck already you can now
install windows on it valve has released
the additional drivers necessary
including drivers for gpu wi-fi and
bluetooth audio drivers however are
still in the works for now users can not
dual boot and only windows 10 can be
installed so windows 11 fans will have
to wait a little longer for that
capability but alright if you're
anything like me and you haven't played
marvel's guardians of the galaxy then
you might want to check it out on game
pass it's available right now and you
should consider this your reminder to
download it when this video ends in
three
two
one